all right so saved by the bell is gonna
have a reboot
let it go you're gonna have reboot
reboot i think it might be just a
one-time thing oh just one time i think
so
and uh mario lopez is the gym coach yep
and then also
zach morris mark paul golf so he's going
to be in it so he's doing like a one
season
i don't really know so it's going to air
right before thanksgiving which i think
is cool
because it just brings you back to that
feeling they're not going to have uh
dustin diamonds no screech and no lisa
the black girl lisa why is she kind of
what she went crazy
are they gonna have my girl uh jesse yes
who i love i like you
yeah yeah you know what was jessie the
girl that taught me how to show girls
she was like i'm so excited she took
caffeine pills yeah
[Music]
this is the max right here and then that
guy he's going to be in it too that dude
that worked at the max yeah he looks so
different he's gonna be a bit of a
bummer though well that'd be sad if the
homie was just still working there
though
no i'm not right what if he owns it
maybe he owns that no i was about to say
he franchised them he's like i have 17
of these
little [ __ ] that's all right i get it
that'd be dope yeah it's not going to
happen but yeah
my boss kelly kelly okay cool because i
always had a couch
who didn't okay my favorite was lisa and
kelly i love lisa
was so freaking cute i was like i was
like screech you don't have a chance dog
remember when they didn't
remember when they did save by the bell
summer edition then that fine ass girl
showed up the lifeguard
was her dad owned the the lyra the
resort who she she went on to king and
queens king and queens king of queens
right yeah king of queens oh she played
the life
scientology girl mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she was so
bad when she was younger didn't they
have another battery on saved by college
or something like that
college yes they had college years yeah
what was the bad evening mike gullick
was the uh the the roommate there she go
yeah she was so bad in that
she had that little deep little raspy
voice a little bit
come on man you ever listen to her with
your eyes closed mm-hmm
hell yeah yeah she was fine as [ __ ] was
it zach's girlfriend
uh i don't care hold on not
because shelley came back and it was
over here
not just what the hell that is no that
wasn't a different way yeah the blonde
one was the
kelly kapowski really grew into herself
in the college she did god damn yeah
that's
her the blonde she was she but the mic
she wants [ __ ] [ __ ] but the mike golic
the big thick roommate
oh you don't remember him no i don't
even remember dude i never got this far
yeah i was i was i wasn't invested oh
you ain't real fans then
yeah screech uh screech did porno so
they can't have a minute huh
he didn't oh then he also did a tell all
books someone too
he stabs on
book he was saying how like they're
having like orgies and [ __ ] and i guess
they were like [ __ ] fans yeah like
that yeah they were screes was [ __ ]
fans
screech wasn't but that zach and mario
lopez was
according to [ __ ] dustin diamond
which is why he's not in the reboot
bro hey dudes like what tell it what to
tell it all he had nothing that he had
nothing going on everyone else like
flourished yeah because wait that's well
he was a great actor though i liked him
was he
i like his little cat scenes like
catchphrases with the little face
the scooby-doo yeah yeah you know what
i'm talking about i was good
like that's good me up right
yeah he's not doing well see shia
labeouf is the more successful version
of him
with like chinese success where like he
took such a better path
yeah screech mario lopez probably the
most successful but then uh
homeboy zachary morrison yeah he's
successful yeah he does a lot of shows
but i mean mario he hasn't his skin
seems to have
like stayed the same oh dude that's a
beautiful he's a good looking dude yeah
yeah freeze he shows up the wild card
every now and
then yeah i did his podcast and um i
wouldn't say we got into it but he was
like used for boxing i was sorry
you went with him i remember i told you
i was like oh i thought he's gonna kick
us out at that moment i really felt like
it's not
really it got kind of heated but then
brandon actually said everything brennan
said
came true like mario he he didn't think
that connor and
floyd would ever fight he's like that's
his jokes why were you talking about it
was like no it's gonna happen you say
i'm not even entertained
like [ __ ] i work for a show at times
it's happening doug yeah damn you did
that
y'all yo you guys are cool though yeah
well cool i mean we don't
y'all kick it a lot and stuff no go hang
on cool but but also
he like in podcasting like he's so stuck
because he worked for
you know extra the hollywood actor and
all that so he's like hey mario lopez
here like
what turn it off there's no cameras
though it's
like good to see you brendan i'm like
why are you acting like this yeah
and why do you have full makeup on it's
a pop right you ever notice
every time you go to stay at a hotel you
turn on the tv his ass is on it he's
all right yeah no no no like just the oh
for the tv yeah he'll be like this week
hannibal too
yeah yeah he does all that [ __ ] every
time you go to hotel turn on that tv
that's so funny it's the first thing you
see that's so fake
that's fake that boy getting paid yeah
i got i got what's in that face bro i
gotta work on my i got the face i gotta
work on my white
person voice let's try it okay let's
give it a shot
actually extra act
no but you got to go hey it's malik b
yeah yeah hey it's malik b
nope no you sound like you smooth jazz
that's pretty much it when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son